-Welcome back, everybody.
Ariana Grande is joining us!
Ah!
We talked about so many things.
You have the secret thing
coming out.
That's all good stuff.
-The secret thing, man.
-I know, I know. I want to
talk about "The Voice."
Live shows start next week.
-Yes.
-This is your first season
on the --
Are you enjoying it so far?
-I'm loving it so much.
I love everybody on set.
I love the coaches.
I love my contestants.
They are so talented.
I believe in them so much.
Like, I know this is just
a starting point for everybody,
and knowing that, of course,
we want them to win, of course,
but just the fact that this is
here and the world gets to
fall in love with them and to be
a part of it is so special,
I -- I'm so thankful to be
a part of it and --
-You're such a good coach.
-It alleviates -- Thank you.
It just alleviates so much
pressure knowing that
this is already happening and
it's going to happen for them.
You know?
I'm sorry, I'm just so excited.
I'm their stage mother.
-I will say, I mean, this is
one of the best seasons.
You guys got to check it out.
It's really a great season.
I'm not just saying that.
But when we were doing
our secret project thing,
you were going into --
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know what to call it.
I keep talking about the secret.
But you kept going -- when you
were getting hair and makeup,
you were watching "The Voice."
-I know!
-Because you were that invested
and you were like,
"Dude, I have to --
These are my babies, man.
I've got to root for
these guys."
And I was like,
"Dude, you really love it."
-We're in a group chat,
and when it's happening live,
they're all talking about what's
happening and how excited
they are for one another, and
it's so sweet and so supportive,
and I'm like, "I have to be
involved in this.
I want to watch."
And so I watch.
-Good chemistry though, you
and Kelly and Blake and John,
you guys -- we all hung out
together for "That's My Jam,"
but you all got along with
each other, like, so well.
You and Blake are
a team on our show,
and I love that combo of --
-Oh, we sure are.
-Yeah. Because it's Blake
and you, and it's just so cute.
[ Laughter ]
It's just perfect.
You've done collaborations
with Kelly.
You've done with John.
Can we see maybe an Ariana/
Blake Shelton collaboration?
-I mean, I would --
Personally, I would love that.
I'm a little bit surprised that
he hasn't reached out yet.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, for me to be on the remix
of his most recent single
titled,
"When I Die, I Hope I Come Back
as a Country Boy."
I personally feel
that I'm a perfect fit
for something like that.
-Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
That is actually a great idea.
I'll put a call in to his agent.
Yeah, we'll talk.
We'll figure it out.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone --
-Let me know.
-I want to show everyone a clip
of Ariana Grande on "The Voice."
Take a look at this.
-I am drained emotionally.
[ Laughter ]
Those performances were
so next-level incredible.
Jershika, your ability to make
everyone in the room feel
what you are feeling
at the same time is special.
-Thank you!
-Paris, I started welling up
while you were singing
'cause your ability to storytell
and move everybody.
I have no idea what I would do
here at all.
Can we change the rules
of the show just this once?
[ Laughter ]
You've got a pull.
-This is my show.
-Come on!
-[ Laughs ]
"This is my show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you get emotional when
contestants have to leave?
-I do.
You really form a relationship
with them
when you're working with them
and just over the course
of the show and I --
They're so talented
and I really believe in
them all.
And like I said before,
the thing that alleviates
any sort of stress or pressure
is the fact that
they have already had this
amazing platform and opportunity
for people to see them
and fall in love with them,
and I know they're all going to
have such amazing music careers
and I'm so excited to see
what happens for them.
-All these people, yeah,
when you see them,
and vote for them and make
Ariana win, please.
We want --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Make them win. It's them.
Yeah, yeah.
-It's them. They win.
Yeah, I know.
Let's see. We talked about
that, secret thing.
We talked about this,
"The Voice."
-I feel like an agent.
Look at my little headphones.
I feel like a Hollywood agent.
-Could you get me a part,
yeah, on Nickelodeon?
-I'm like, "Jimmy, you got
the call back."
[ Laughter ]
"They loved ya."
-"They loved ya.
You're a little green."
Let's see. Did I miss --
Did we miss anything?
-I don't know, man.
-Oh, what's going on --
-Oh! Yes.
I have a makeup line that is
dropping on Friday, next Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is exciting.
-You're doing everything!
You're unbelievable!
Wait, you have
a whole makeup line?
-Yes, but it pales in comparison
to your skin-care routine
that I saw.
[ Laughter ]
I love you, I'm sorry.
I'll drop it. I'll drop it.
It's a joke.
It's part of the secret thing.
-Oh, my gosh, that was
so embarrassing.
But yours is real.
You have a real skin care --
beauty stuff coming out.
-Yes. It's happening.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Who doesn't?
No, I'm kidding.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's always a pleasure
talking to you.
I'm going to text you after this
just to tell you
how much I love you.
-Please. I love you so much.
This was so much fun,
and I miss being there in person
and I miss New York. I love you.
-I had so much fun with you that
I can't even talk about
how much fun Ariana Grande is.
The most fun, coolest
human being on Earth.
-I love you.
Ariana Grande, everyone!
-I love you!
-"The Voice" airs Mondays and
Tuesdays at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.